Lily hello ru we're gonna do this one in
English if you don't mind for are you
excited to do that well first of all
lots to celebrate tonight but let's get
fashion out of the way because I mean
wow who you were okay can we get a
little spin because if people could see
the train it is ruffled feathers to the
night I mean how's it feel to be here
performing and AH now on the red carpet
at the Latin Grammy amazing is I think
it's the first time going to come here
with with a song you know not only just
being an influence or now being an
artist and I'm super excited super
blessed and I'm happy people liked the
song and it just went triple platinum so
I'm really excited
oh do you already feel like a winner
tonight because you had an amazing year
I mean I'm presenting but maybe
hopefully next year I'll be nominated
absolutely do you have any um pre-show
rituals or maybe even before a red
carpet especially this one cuz it's a
big one like Rachel's what I do yeah
what do you do you listen to music do
music I listen to my Kareena that's how
I calm myself down so it's the one that
started all I feel with the crossovers
that we've been having a lot right I
know yeah speaking of crossovers is
there anyone you're dying to work with
someone you want to get on a track with
or maybe someone you know what I think I
want to do it with someone that is like
I'm like Spain or like Brazil obviously
you need that but somewhere that is like
in a different place a different
platform like I'm not doing a background
just one like even like you like Europe
would you consider among your peers here
you know your go to your confidant your
ride or die someone that when you run
into on the red carpet you just feel
like at home I really can
J Balvin oven I cannot wait to sees
performance you guys both got like a
similar vibe going with their dresses
except she's in pea and real quick who
you excited to see tonight uh perform
there's a lot of amazing performers so G
right good luck to you look at you have
fun presenting great to meet you
[Music]
[Applause]